Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house.
Christina.
Chinese eyes,
British Elle.
I'm Chinese eyes British though.
I'm Chinese eyes.
[inaudible]
Marion Barry.
What's up
man?
What's up bear.
Mary Berry.
Groupon.
Groupon,
man.
Groupon.
He retarded.
K gets dressed as juicy as my pussy.
Question.
Kay.
Gifts.
Just as juicy as my pussy.
Question
marks marks.
Barry.
Barry,
what's up man?
You retarded.
Retarded.
Retargeting,
retargeting,
retargeting.
There you go.
Um,
that was the great British baking show recap that we did last time.
Man,
you sound worse than me.
Why worser?
Well,
we both have aids.
We both got aids this week.
Our House is covered in aids because our kid has it and then we got it.
Yeah.
No,
you're going to sound like this and a few days,
God,
I'm a few days ahead of you.
It's really fun.
I'm trying to,
whenever this isn't working,
so next time.
So our boy has had two colds in this.
One might.
He's 15 months old and it's been too cold.
We somehow didn't get the first,
the second one hit and everybody's gone.
I thought I was in the clear yeah,
cause I left town.
Yeah.
And um,
you got it.
I got it.
The nanny got it.
We all got it now in the nannies,
families getting get it,
you know what I started to feel,
it's such a drag.
It was a,
so I did,
I did Pittsburgh,
Pittsburgh,
um,
new haven.
I'm sorry,
where did you haven,
Connecticut.
Yup.
June.
I also did a Burlington coat factory.
You're gonna like the way you look.
So different one.
But uh,
so I was fine for to everything.
Yeah.
Third.
Oh,
the third show of the week was the first show in Vermont.
Yeah.
I'm doing the meet and greet and I just start to feel Vicky.
Oh,
so you,
you made it to Vermont,
so you made it like a day.
Two days,
two days.
The third day of the thing.
And then I'm like kind of,
I start to feel just shitty onstage,
uh,
for the last show and I go,
oh see,
I didn't know if I was getting sick or just as an exhaustion.
Sometimes you just have exhaustion,
feels the same road sick and cold,
sick in the beginning they're similar.
And then when I got up for the flight yesterday,
I was like,
oh,
I feel like shit right now.
You got the aids.
We both got it and I'll tell you,
I just canceled my whole week.
I got to recover for this weekend coming up.
Here's the deal with,
I have a weekend to,
I'm in Brad this weekend so we can't fuck around.
The thing no one tells you with kids is that you get whatever sickness they have
and then there's no time to recover because you're still having to be a pure,
there's no day off.
Like you just wake up sick and horrible and then you take care of this kid.
So you've really got to take care of downtime when you can to recover.
Otherwise you're just going to roll into another sickness pre,
pre real pretty real.
But we're here,
we're queer and we're nonbinary and Holly and we're going to make the best of
it.
Chinese,
British mouth.
Mary Berry,
Cheng likes to fuck my aunt.
That's a long title,
but thank you Andre.
I,
where did the Chinese eyes part come from?
I don't remember saying that about my impression.
Oh yeah,
cause you I like,
oh 40 fall to fall.
I think that's not,
no,
I didn't go
Chinese accent and Chinese eyes.
Well then show me how it's done,
right.
British accent.
Chinese eyes,
Show me how you doing?
I guess I was going like,
yes,
you can't quite put your finger on.
Yeah,
like that now I,
I fell asleep last night during the great British baking show.
Season three we're about,
how far are we now?
Episode six.
We're getting in there.
Yeah,
we're down to the final six now.
What happened on that final cut?
No.
Tell me who they were.
Who did you see get cut last?
I didn't,
I fucking spaced out.
I thought you watched one with me and we started another one,
but I forget.
Oh [inaudible] are you [inaudible] go Ukrainia I was rooting for acne.
I liked her blue eyeshadow.
Spoiler alert.
Alan got the ax.
Alvin is white guy.
No,
no.
Well,
you know his bags were very imprecise.
He had timing issues.
That's what I was his undoing.
Yeah.
Is that he uh,
yeah,
he missed time to come.
You have more things,
you know,
and here's the thing,
except for the middle challenge.
Yeah.
You've got time.
You have a whole week to prepare your banks,
your signature bake and the show stopper even an entire week to prepare.
So there's no excuse for you to not be to time.
You should be practicing at home all fucking week.
Dude.
Sounds like discipline.
Serious flood been on reality shows.
Guys,
I know how this goes.
I know how this works.
When the great British baking show,
you sound like a five year old smoker.
It's kind of fun.
I think I would be the worst contestant I am.
I have no patience for baking because that involves precision measuring
patients.
I have none of those things.
You would be great though.
The irony is,
is that you're a better cook you or better.
You're a better baker.
You're better at that kind of stuff than me.
I have no patience.
I don't think that's entirely,
you made,
remember the the time we gained 50 pounds eating pecan pies.
Who was making those?
Yeah,
I was the real thing that I missed that I used to make as chocolate souffle.
Those were outstanding,
but they're not good for you either.
They're not know what's wrong with them.
They have a little bit of sugar.
God,
I can't even guess how many grams.
Do you know how we used to eat treats like that?
Every night.
Every night we would make souffle's awesome.
Let's make brownies.
Okay,
let's do cookies.
Yeah,
and it wouldn't be to have a bite either.
Like let's try and remember,
you and I,
we both have this thing where we like it.
Piping hot.
Any treat has to be hot,
hot,
hot.
I hate it when you go.
Like I remember I went to a friend's house and she made la lime lemon bars and I
fucking hate lemon bars to begin with and she was like,
let's wait for them to cool.
Never enjoy a cold treat.
The treat has to be warm.
If it's out of the oven,
it should be burning your mouth.
And that's how you know what's good.
Let's,
uh,
let's open this show up and we'll get back into it.
All right,
let's do the show cause soggy bottom.
Tonight I'm going to answer your questions about the feces fail.
Now the face spell is traditionally a spill that you can do on a person to get
rid of them out of your life.
Yeah.
How old is Randy?
Well,
we'll go to your mom's house,
Christina.
It's interesting.
Probably way too loud.
If you're wondering this lady here,
she can see that she is,
uh,
from a,
a build the black,
which coven?
The coven carbon.
Uh,
their,
their Facebook group description.
It says the Blackwood coven is an online international group of eclectic
witches,
Gypsies,
warlocks and Oculus,
I call it.
Sorry.
Oh yeah,
you're right.
I'm sick.
Led by black,
which s
before.
So you can tell there's a whole group of people out there,
you know,
listen to me,
you piece of box,
the one,
I'm not bisexual too.
I'm not gay.
Three.
No,
I'm not God damn fat.
I'm skinny as hell.
And I'm fucking Wiccan.
Do you have a problem?
You can go fuck yourself.
Piece of shit.
Somebody say,
remember that everybody,
there's a Wiccan was a fat fucking retard.
That guy got really mad.
It's funny cause on.
That's deep bro.
I had a woman email me saying that she was awakened and she lives in this
conservative town and she asked me whether or not she should be out and proud as
a witch.
Yeah.
And I said absolutely not.
The out of your fucking mind.
Yeah.
There,
you know,
not,
not everything needs to be out and proud.
There's keep that shit to yourself a lot.
You should keep to yourself.
Oh,
lots of things that this generation's obsessed.
Everything has to be accepted and out and proud.
No,
you don't.
Some things you just,
it's not that you should be ashamed,
but just anybody value privacy.
Keep it to fucking self.
I don't want to fucking tell everybody everything about me.
I don't either.
So weird that people were like,
and my greatest thrill was sharing everything about me with the world.
Why?
I don't even share my kids' pictures online.
No,
I know,
you know,
but I share other things on this CBRE obviously.
Yeah,
I share this stuff.
I choose to share but not every fucking detail.
Yeah,
they got a fart.
Well,
I don't know.
It kind of dicey right now.
Why?
Why are your bowel movements so di Dicey today?
Um,
you know when you get sick you just feel different.
I think it affects everything and the eating takes usually a bit of a dip or a
change.
I barely ate this week.
All I feel like eating is melted cheese on a plate.
Yeah.
I just been eaten there.
I feel like I don't know what I want to eat.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Learning tastes get when we have a cold and I think kinda tastes like shit,
you know what I want to eat is melted cheese on the plate.
It's crackers and then chocolate chip cookies like,
doesn't that sound good?
That sounds good.
What do you miss the most of sugar of sugar if so much of it.
He said Waffles last time,
but I feel like it's different when you're sick.
Yeah,
I would like just warm pastry kind of stuff.
Um,
Chucky croissants.
Shopkeepers or maybe a Kinda know I want like,
I just won't warm doughy stuff.
Sugar.
Yeah.
Pastries.
So,
uh,
so last time I went past it passes.
That's all you can eat when you're sick.
Really should be eating carbs.
So the Filipino guy got kicked off.
Was He devastated?
He was,
um,
he knew it was coming I think because he had three basically he had one really
bad showing first one,
second to last in the middle.
And then when the third thing he,
he,
they were like,
you have to just crush it on this one.
The,
the um,
the show stopper.
Yeah.
And He,
uh,
he missed time then under.
Yeah.
But see,
there's no excuse on the technical,
I'm sorry.
On the show stopper.
The technical challenge.
Dickies throat.
They're throwing you curve balls.
You have to rely on your knowledge of baking.
Yeah.
But the show stopper,
and you should have that one down.
When you come into the ring,
there's no excuse to have a Porsche fucking,
yeah.
You gotta bring it stopped the show.
And there's no soggy modems.
No.
Nope.
It did really break shit down.
Like looking at it and he's like,
this is a good finish at the bottom.
Like really inspecting it.
Yeah.
I don't,
I feel like Paul Hollywood doesn't really fit into that cast.
Like he looks like a douchebag.
He's got the jelled hair,
he's got the Douchebag,
goatee,
the douchebag uniform,
like the light denim and then like the colorful button down shirt and like
douchey shoes.
Like he doesn't fit in to the great British baking show.
Well,
I think he's supposed to not fit in other words.
Right.
It's made up of the every man,
right.
That people are just,
they're amateur.
Right.
The total Lesbos,
the one lazboy hosts,
and then like the more hetero appearing,
I don't want to say it's Pronoun.
You really are.
You're being very,
very insensitive.
Yeah.
He is the celebrity chef on the show,
so he's,
he's supposed to be like,
I'm not like you.
I'm different than you.
I'm above you.
Right.
I think that's what comes across.
You would be great at that,
at being above you.
Yeah.
No.
You know what's funny?
I was thinking about this.
Yeah,
you say that I'm the elitist.
You know you're like it,
but I was really thinking about it.
You're far more
of an elitist.
You know why you think every place that isn't here is dog shit.
You're like,
give us not California except place.
People don't know that about you,
but you really shit on places and that's a way more elitist than you call me for
liking a nice things.
You know?
You're like,
oh,
that's a nice Tamia like it.
But you're like,
what?
Garbage dump outside of California.
I call it everywhere outside of La is just not la.
Like I don't want to know the name of the place.
I don't want you to lead.
It's not la.
You're such an elitist.
Well,
let me explain.
First of all,
La is the best.
Okay?
We have the best climate.
We had the best looking people and we have the best produce,
the best Mexican food.
That's true.
We have lawyers,
we have the Lakers,
bro,
bro.
We got to in all nationalities,
everybody fucking lives here.
You've got two new football teams to new football teams.
What's not to love the ocean mountains.
I can go snowboard in the morning and then go surf in the afternoon.
It's amaze.
What is amaze and what is amazing,
what's not amazing about La might say.
Do you think that any of that makes you not an elitist now?
It makes me a loyalist.
I would say.
Wow.
Semantics Ron.
I know if it,
doesn't everybody feel that way about their home?
A lot of people do.
A lot of people are just like,
you know,
Toledo is the best.
Yeah.
They love in Akron.
I probably be like fuck everywhere else besides not Akron,
but I'm really an Angeleno but that's cause I'm ride or die.
Like I grew up here since I was four.
This is my home.
This is my fucking,
he went eight till I die,
Bro.
Yeah,
yeah.
But I called you was it?
And I go,
it's snowing and you go,
why do you go to these awful places?
Snow to me is inexcusable.
Like I can't even fathom living in it.
I hate going to it.
Nothing makes me sadder than snow.
Snow in April when you're in some poor city.
And you're just like,
well,
these poor people have to live indoors for just five months.
Right.
Since then,
since October,
they've been in indoor since October.
It's fucking April.
Let the people outside,
let them have son.
That's what I feel like.
I feel bad for them.
I feel fucking and I'm like,
I can't do it.
You gave me the fuck Outta here.
I mean,
my father had that same feeling in Canada.
He was like,
oh,
this fucking called it snow.
This.
Yeah,
this is the best then fuck it.
Fuck it dude.
I don't want to like wear coats and be unhappy and all that.
Kind of like the seasons.
Actually.
I really do.
I do.
I like the seas of fucking throw up,
right?
I do.
What about it?
I don't even know you.
I'm serious.
I'm so upset right now.
I like fall.
I love you don't get a real proper one here.
It's,
it gets down to 60 I got to put it like a sweater on.
No,
because the hottest ones here are our autumn.
Sure feared a little bit.
That's September,
October,
actually hotter than July and October.
It's like the hottest month.
Yeah.
So then November becomes basically autumn.
You know it's perfect.
November,
December and then
yes,
as you don't really get a proper one Christmas,
it dips down into 70 yeah.
Christmas morning for this Chili got to turn that heater on.
The nighttime can get down to 46 degrees c but I like the,
I'm saying those days are like basically what a normal autumn feels like.
I liked those days a lot.
I like on them days.
Yeah.
Now you got upset this this year because of the rain.
Fuck.
You hated it and it got very mad.
See,
you don't like whether you say you do and then when you live in it,
it's mostly around though we misery.
We had three months of basically nonstop downpour.
I know.
Remember when you want it to live in Seattle for a minute,
you will like,
let's move to Seattle or Portland and I was like,
Bro,
you don't know what you're saying.
Not Rain is real.
I still want to move to Colorado.
I love Colorado.
It's not la though.
I know.
That'll be it.
That'll be the whole thing.
That'll happen if we moved anywhere.
What's the problem is that it's not here.
Here's going to be the problem.
There's no proper Mexican food in Denver,
and I know we're going to get emails and no Mexicans that lived,
not like La Mexicans.
Well,
yeah,
I know,
but there's still Mexican.
They left Mexico.
It's not the same.
Don't they always make the food to go with the tastes of the locals?
For instance,
I was in Kansas City once and I saw there was a Mexican dude in the kitchen and
I go,
Bro,
don't give me this fucking dog shit on the menu.
You give me what you're having for lunch.
Give me what the busboys and you guys are eating.
And he made me Mexican food,
but it was diluted.
It was like double down because all the honkies are eating it.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay.
They still give you like the white man version that bothers you.
Yeah,
we're right on the border,
Bro.
We're right near Mexico.
We're right there.
Okay.
Uh,
do you feel this way for like Bill Milwaukee or a Florida?
No,
no.
I love La.
I love living in La.
What's your favorite place to live so far?
You Oh,
here?
Yeah,
for sure.
absolutely the longest.
I mean,
I like it here,
but I do like Tattoo Bro.
La.
I do like other cities too that you don't like any other?
No,
I'm just kidding.
I here's the cities I like.
Let's be real,
real talk.
I'm going to upset a lot of people.
The big ones.
Leighton name a big one.
They're all good in America.
Yeah.
I like Miami.
Miami's like La Times a hundred.
It's ridiculous,
right?
Yeah.
I like New York.
Obviously.
Seattle,
Portland,
Austin.
Okay.
Minneapolis.
Tits is great.
All the biggers.
Yeah.
Sanford,
Sanford and friend to I lived in San Francisco.
Love it.
Yeah.
San Diego,
Sacramento,
San Jose.
Those are all good places to California cities.
I like mom.
[inaudible] I like all these places.
This is my favorite.
Yeah,
I just don't think I could live.
I would cause I'd be very like,
what would,
what would we live in there?
You just get used to living in this climate all the time.
It really is a weather thing too.
And like a lifestyle.
I don't mind sitting in my car for an hour.
I want you to really pay attention to the weather.
That's a good month.
That's a really good,
here's my problem with Denver.
Snow's and it gets cold.
It doesn't get that cold.
Sure does for me.
Yeah.
But it doesn't get like Chicago cold.
That's that cold is real.
I don't know how people strive.
Brutal.
Cold.
Where's the coldest in America?
Uh,
it's constantly North Dakota.
Oof.
Minneapolis,
Minnesota like is actually colder and God damn those poor people.
You just get used to it.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
absolutely.
You got used to it.
How long would you think it would take me?
Someone who is like almost born and bred in la.
Yeah,
I five years.
I mean,
the second time it came around you'd be like,
Oh fuck this again,
third,
fourth,
fifth time.
And you'd just be like,
yeah,
this is how it is.
Because some of those fools go out and like a thin jacket dude.
Like I come,
I come rock in a Parka spaces.
Is that real?
I'm serious.
Yeah,
because you're,
I was walking around,
uh,
Burlington and the coat factory,
the coke factory,
and it was a,
I don't know,
it was a cool day,
but for me like I wanted a hat and a jacket and everything cause I'm not used to
it.
And I saw,
you know,
college kids walking around and tee shirts because,
because comparison to what they were coming out of their winner,
this was a much warmer day.
That's how I used to be tourist.
When you see them in La and then they're there in the water and our ocean and
February and you're like,
that's a Canadian because I should,
does not phase them but an Angeleno it'd be like hell no,
let's wait until August before anybody goes in there.
No,
it's a,
it's very much you get,
you adapt,
your body adapts.
When I moved to Florida,
I moved in November and I had been living in Cincinnati,
Minneapolis in Milwaukee.
I moved in November to Florida in Florida in November where I lived,
it was probably like 50 something.
They were all in sweatshirts and jackets and I was in a t shirt like sweating.
People thought I was mentally ill.
What is wrong with you,
man?
It's like I just moved from somewhere where it's fucking five degrees outside,
so 55 it's fucking awesome.
Yeah,
but some of the next year,
but I had a sweatshirt on.
Oh yeah,
get used to.
It used to be hot all the time.
Yeah.
You're not used to being warm enough.
You still are like it's hot.
Yeah,
but you
always insist on it being freezing cold and our bedroom and the office.
You have to get you.
Here's the thing,
you have to let la like the heat just get in you bro.
You gotta like it's 15 but you got to live in a nice,
let yourself be warm.
Do you let your son,
many of the spells that you can do just to get somebody away for her tits are
going to fall right out of that address.
The next level causing harm.
Before you do this,
you're susy Su,
very god,
before you put in the effort to actually do this master of accident.
Where is she?
Has this New Zealand or is this Australia?
No,
but can I ask you about eyeshadow?
Yeah.
Is it normally the eyelid and then the whole eye area?
Only if you're a 15 and goth.
But like normally what do you know?
When I was golf,
this is how you're,
this is how Susie,
Susie,
the banshees did her and that's how we did it.
And what do you do now?
Look at what I do now.
Natural.
But you do the whole area though.
You're not supposed to put eye shadow from the bottom of your lid up to your
eyebrow.
And then around the eye it looks crazy.
Eye socket like no dude,
that's like the woman,
first of all,
that's how I know the bitch is crazy.
Number two,
when the bitch draws the lip liner around the lip,
if you know bitch,
that draws the lip liner up over the line in the mouth and then she fills it in
like that's her lip,
please bitch,
please.
The feces.
So she does that too.
Insane that the feces spells to do is quite simple.
The idea is to get some toy,
I use the fucking shit.
What you do is you write the name of that person on the paper and then what
you're really doing is going in there,
you taking a shit on the paper and you're flushing them out of your life.
Wow.
I think that's uh,
actually just something you should probably do.
That's a,
it seems every day.
Well,
every day.
But it also seems like that makes a lot of sense.
Maybe just the mental process of doing that feels probably very cleansing.
No anything.
Yeah.
It's very cathartic.
It's also,
um,
a colossal waste of time.
No hostile guy.
No.
I said,
sorry.
A colossal,
a colossal waste of your energy,
isn't it?
Probably to really hate that person.
How about just forget it.
Let it go.
Good therapist and go take a shit on this paper.
Flush them
Jane Lane or a beginner beginner maybe takes us three months to do.
Oh my God.
Wow.
Every day.
Many people like to hear,
but that's a reality.
All of it
a long time to get into state and to focus and actually believe.
So hang in there.
Be patient,
but remember this
is a spell to cause harm to someone you really don't like.
So use it with caution.
Now I know they're are going to spill out of her mushers or throw.
The bat is hanging.
He's mine now as somebody that was golf in high school and I read a lot about
witchcraft and all this stuff.
You're not supposed to do black magic.
Why not?
Because it's rooted in bad and it's just going to come back and get you.
Everybody knows that he shit on the paper.
Everybody knows.
Everybody knows you're I supposed to do that.
Bad Karma dip shit.
Big asshole.
Stupid,
Huh?
Yup.
Would you do a spell?
I would do it.
A fart spell.
I would do that shit.
Spell the feces spell.
I don't see why not.
Why does our car smelled bad?
We talk about that.
That was,
you know,
it happened to both vehicles.
Yours and mine had stinky air conditioners.
I don't know.
It was really upsetting.
Well,
but what causes that smell like bong smelled real,
real bad.
Real bunk
for turn on the car and it was like the car was
good,
like a car,
you Naz Jihad.
I took mine in and they go,
well you know Rodens borough in the engines,
you know,
maybe we'll find a decompose and that's what you're smelling them through your,
I was like,
ah,
file dog.
And then,
uh,
he checked mine out and was like,
no,
it wasn't there.
It just smells like farts.
And he's like,
we just cleaned everything,
change the filter smell better.
Or your air conditioner just started smelling like Fart song.
Yeah.
Do you think it's from your farts in the car?
I didn't ask,
but it didn't seem like that would make sense.
Like a forensic autopsy or whatever on the car and the,
I don't know.
Um,
but then yours started to see,
you're starting to smell later.
Maybe all your parts built up in there.
You,
I thought it might be because I,
sometimes I make like a cucumber apple,
like blended shake things and I leave it in there.
They mentioned that.
Actually no,
they really did because when I picked yours up they kept it for three days to do
this.
Um,
he's like,
I think the smell is pretty much taken care of,
but there's like a juice thing in there and got my smell now cause it's just
been left in there.
Anyway.
Thanks for leaving it guys.
You think I wanted to save that?
Yeah.
Thank you.
That's very courteous.
Did you leave the empty yet?
70 in there
to collapse everything.
Thanks guys.
Leave it exactly as I gave it to you.
Pretty cool.
I need it exact.
Yeah.
Well I'm curious so they don't have any theories other than a dead rodent.
Yeah,
he's like are,
you know like the filters could just be filthy,
but that's what it is.
The air filter.
It didn't make that much sense though.
God change the air filter.
Get Old.
Huh?
Who's that?
That's the guy that told you.
Okay.
Yeah,
they were terrible.
It was terrible at your yours,
the car service.
Yeah,
they kept the car for fucking three days,
Bro.
I basically had the fuckers routine service and I was like,
oh,
also when you check out the air conditioning,
it smells,
how long will this tag is?
Like 60,
90 minutes.
And I was like,
yeah,
I'll go home.
Just call me.
He's like,
oh,
we need to keep it overnight.
And I go,
oh please,
you went from 60 minutes to 90 minutes to overnight and that sounds really good.
And I know we all have a mute button.
Yeah,
well we do actually a cough button on like there's a I can,
I can take care of you.
There you go.
Now no one hears.
Well,
somewhat muted.
You done,
you're finished.
You're finished.
You're done.
Um,
and then he called me the second day.
Yeah,
we need to give her the again.
I'm like,
what are you fucking doing to this thing man?
Oh the road is
so lame.
Stupid.
Fart.
Take off the whole dashboard.
We know every car I've owned eventually smells funky though.
I had a Volkswagen Jetta.
Remember that one?
And that one smelled like crayons for years.
Yeah,
no,
I blame it on an accident I got into,
I got rear ended and the trunk was jammed open and it rained in the trunk and I
think it got moldy and the smart,
it smelled of crayons for years.
That's possible.
Yeah.
Before that,
my Chevy Nova,
I just smoked cigarettes and they're in the ashtray.
Gnarly.
I know.
Isn't that crazy?
Now to think about that.
Whenever I see anyone smoking in their car.
Roseola Lailey yeah.
Hard fucking core.
Right?
Especially when you see really nice cars.
Yeah.
I was just at a red light.
I see this brand new Lexus next to me and you see the window cracked this much
and the person just smoking.
I'm like,
you're smoking in the nasty brand.
Beautiful,
beautiful car.
I know.
No regard.
I mean,
the worst obviously is windows up.
Like you have to be on real lunatic.
Just sit in that dude.
And people did,
I mean back in the nineties eighties dude,
you'd see that Ah,
this nasty fucking nasty.
And this again,
it's Timmy Hill 2.0 prior job to hear speed up here.
This is a sanitation driver.
So you can hear me better.
He held 2.0 going after the mattress Nacho,
without getting out.
I looked like fun.
Try to grab a mattress without getting out there.
Getting out 11.
Who's driving the sanitation truck and he's using the claw basically,
right the arm to see if he can do it.
Uh,
like basically,
I hope my ankle doesn't get bad,
but
do it.
Did he's got it so far.
Yeah.
Turn,
turn,
turn.
He's turning it all right.
Sweet.
And she's killing it.
Look at it.
Turn.
Okay,
let's pause here.
Oh.
It's spending a lot.
He's doing it.
Yup.
Does it?
Ooh.
Okay.
All right.
We got a good grip.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
Look at the other guy.
Any other trends you guys did?
I'm so cool.
Yup.
Good for him.
Yeah,
I bet that took years of experience.
That was a oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
You can't do that first week on the job.
Hell no,
no,
no.
Good for him.
That was funny.
Yeah.
Let's do something not so funny.
Oh No.
Hello.
I'm thank you for joining us and covering your dometic 300 series RV toilet to
operate your dometic RV toilet first.
Add water bowl.
No Shit.
We down on the pedal watershed enter the bowl.
But the flushing mechanism should not.
If the flushing mechanism opens,
release pressure off the pedal until water only water in the bowl prevents odors
from entering the RV and it may be necessary to have water before flushing
solids or toilet paper.
To flush your dometic toilet,
press down all the way on the pedal or liquids.
Press down for one to two seconds or solid.
Hold the pedal down as long as necessary to remove all the contents.
Flush mechanism open for too long.
The wool will your holding tank.
See this is a unique boring video because it's boring and not difficult to
understand.
Right?
So it's a whole new level of boring.
It's boring and like boring and you process basic.
Yeah,
it's almost,
it's almost better to boring not understand it,
right?
Yeah.
Cause I'm challenged.
But that was like double bad.
Yeah.
That's the worst.
And you're like,
I get it,
I get it.
I got it.
Wait,
so I got to hold it flush down the contents go away.
I got it.
Fuck.
What about the Yellow Stupa
I think those cold medicines.
Really Fun.
Did you take
it?
No,
you gotta try it.
It's a fucking party partying right now.
Yeah,
I'm having a great time on the show.
You know what?
Speaking of toilet seat,
I went to see a movie by myself.
I saw trainspotting two fucking awesome,
by the way.
I don't know why nobody's talking about it,
but it's a really good movie.
It stands on its own.
If you haven't seen the first one,
you can see the second one.
Anyways,
I went to go potty and you know,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like a nice theater.
I fucking pull my pants down.
I sit down and it's wet.
Ah.
I sat on a p covered seat.
Bare ass dude.
Tell me all these nasty as hell.
It was so bad and it's happened before.
You know,
that's not the first time.
I just didn't look cause I was out of it.
And sick bed.
Put a nasty bitch.
Just pissing on the seat like a nice theater dude.
Cause so yeah,
we're not at fucking Angel Stadium.
That's gross man.
If you ever done that before,
I've sat on Piss.
Yeah,
it's gross.
It's upsetting.
It's so upsetting because it's like stranger piss.
It's not even somebody,
you know.
That's the worst part about it.
It's like,
who's fucking AIDS?
P is on me.
I don't want it.
Aids p Jesus.
But then I started getting paranoid.
I'm like,
can I catch a disease this way?
Like can I get asked herpes or something
from someone's urine?
No,
it's really sterile.
Actually.
Nothing bad can happen.
Oh my God,
you guys are so disgusting.
You can't get,
you can't get sick.
No.
Right.
I mean it's just on your bud skin.
Like on your thigh skin.
It's fine.
Nothing will happen.
Oh,
speaking of PB,
we took Fifo and Schnitzel to the vet,
uh,
last,
two weeks ago and Fifo.
They took his urine and then we'd get a call three days later.
All the urine samples not strong enough.
I go,
yeah,
well we can't tell it as I concentrated.
You guys need to do is,
uh,
tomorrow morning when he wakes up his first morning pee,
you guys have to collect the first morning pee.
I go,
what?
Okay.
I'm on it.
Yeah.
I go,
how am I supposed to do that?
Well,
you know,
I'm a fucking dog training.
I go,
how am I supposed to do that?
Well,
you know,
he lifts his leg or does he spot I go,
he fucking lives his leg.
He's a real man.
Yeah.
He's a dog not buying.
And uh,
she goes,
well,
what you can do,
you can,
you can get like a Tupperware container and just put it under there when he
lifts his leg in the morning.
I okay.
Yeah.
I acted like,
I mean,
who the fuck is going to do that?
As much as I love Fif I know.
How am I going to even do this?
No,
it's fucking crazy.
If I'm going to fuck my dad was somebody,
I'm going to find out a trained professional though.
Fuck my dog.
Wet.
Yeah.
I mean,
our dog by the way.
I Dunno.
I have some dogs I could see getting away with that.
Our dog,
as soon as you reach down there,
he'd be like,
excuse me,
what are you doing?
And he would hold his pee for eight more hours.
Yeah.
He's not the type of dog that just because I was like,
oh,
okay.
Fiefs not easy going,
you know,
and he's,
he's on the ball.
He knows shit fuse like a person.
He's really smart.
He'll be like,
get the fuck away from me with that shit.
I don't care.
You can dog assholes.
So we're not,
we're not going to know if fiefs kidneys are functioning well because I'm not
going to do that.
Yeah.
Oh.
And then they go,
he has a slight heart murmur.
Here's the,
uh,
here's the heart specialist.
You can take him to.
Hey,
what's so funny about that yet?
I mean,
I love my dog,
but a heart specialist for the fucking dog.
Seriously.
What are we going to give him a heart transplant?
Nope.
Open her dog surgery to see how to what extent the heart is,
uh,
having a murmur so that when you put them under for a mouth cleaning,
that he's right.
He didn't know that the heart specialist will tell you this is the safe range
for anesthesia.
Oh,
that's why.
I thought she wanted us to give him open heart surgery or find a donor.
No.
Give him an Oregon transplant.
Why?
Why am I,
oh,
because I love fucking dogs.
I'm just going to take the dog.
Yeah,
come on.
You have to understand that
linkedin is helpful.
You have to understand that you get that right.
The about the anesthesia.
Yeah.
Yes.
But I,
I just,
it struck me as very ridiculous when I heard that we had to take our fucking 14
pound dog to a cardiologist.
Now get out of here now when you get it.
Uh Huh.
You get that a dog's going under.
He needs the to tolerate a little more DNA.
Well,
why don't you collect his urine tomorrow morning and then I'll take him to the
cardiologist,
stand them up.
We can call it a week.
We can spend $5,000 on this dog's health care.
I would spend it on FIFA.
You want to clone fif?
I do.
I want to clone him for 25,000.
I love beef.
I love him too.
He's the best.
Yeah,
but I don't know how I'm going to collect his urine like that.
That's in,
why can't we just have him bring him in again and have him take your in that
time?
I think what I might ask is if we can bring him in first thing in the morning.
Like Fifa Holds His pee all day.
He hates pink all day.
He hates going outside for any reason.
I mean,
right now he's still asleep on the couch.
He loves it.
He loves being under the covers and sleeping.
He wouldn't eat or pee or shit unless we forced it on heads his life.
Yeah.
No,
that's true.
Bitsy,
on the other hand,
different dog.
Totally trusting would,
let me do that in a minute.
You Want me To pee?
Where like,
you know,
a lot of people,
we have new listeners all the time,
uh,
are always trying to figure out what's the origin of the show.
What's the show actually about?
At our core,
we are denim specialists.
That's what really what this show is about.
I mean,
it's not a mistake that you're wearing that jacket in that course.
So whenever it's possible,
we like to thoroughly dive into the denim world.
Oh,
so finally,
back to our tests.
First thing I would look at would be I guess a stretch.
Is it?
Um,
is it real?
Denim isn't just stretchy cotton.
Taylor Rebbie maternal says overall the quality of all three genes is good,
but finds the ones from target,
which is the most expensive at $10 don't have strong sides stitching.
Wait,
the most expensive is $10.
What genes are they looking into?
I don't know.
Let's see.
I didn't know you could buy jeans for $10 Daily Mail in the UK on the denim for
a couple.
Okay.
They investigated goodness you can get $10.
Yeah.
The idea is the more,
the better.
So this one doesn't have any,
this has one that one has to,
it's the one with the double stitch of the $7 pair from Kmart.
The Hem on those Kmart pair isn't as good as the others are going to rabbit.
I could've told you that there this him compared to that him the quality is
pretty noticeable from the inside and outside.
If you guys are real.
This is like the denim doctor.
Yeah.
I gotta tell you if you're looking for bang for your buck for quality and price,
I think that like old school Levi's with a way to go.
If you don't want to go designer,
you just like standard,
don't you think?
Yeah.
Levi's are,
are are high quality.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
For the money.
If you're not wanting to spend like a hundred dollars
on,
you're a GS and your age.
These are amazing.
They are amazeballs everyone,
your friend's dad came here and we're like,
cool dad jeans.
I forget.
You don't remember that?
My friend's Dad.
Yeah.
Oh yes.
He came over here.
Oh No,
look at his jeans.
Yeah,
he had like,
they were like baggy on the side.
Yeah.
And I was like,
you know,
do you want,
we can go get some uh,
high quality ones.
I gave some nice ones.
Yeah.
The mall.
And he's like,
what do you pay for those?
I said,
I don't know,
like a hundred and something.
He's like,
what are you fucking out of your mind?
Yeah.
It doesn't understand that.
You know,
the genes do really make the person the good genes are everything.
Yeah.
I'm serious.
Like now that I spend a little bit more on jeans,
Hudson's great.
Agee is great.
Yeah.
Lucky brand is great.
Lucky makes good genes.
Cause when was fatter,
I got gray,
had Ellis,
it was really important and it was buying gap jeans.
Those suck.
They're not good.
Not For me.
I wore them for a long time.
Yeah.
They're,
they don't fit as well as lucky for me for some reason.
You just have to find the brand that works for you.
Right.
So think about lucky was there,
they always had crazy sales.
Yeah.
They did a pretty good,
we went there together.
They were like 50% off.
It was crazy.
It's not bad.
It's really good.
Fair jeans.
So which is the overall winner?
So genes overall finish in terms of the quality of finish?
Uh,
regarding the Hem,
the stitching on the waistline.
The fish.
The detail.
Yeah.
I would still go with this one.
The just here from big w currently on sale for $7 $7
and here we're talking about a hundred.
I know Jesus.
But those aren't good jeans.
No.
I know the stitching is bad,
but how did they all stand up after 10 washes?
Oh,
well this is the big w pair.
You can see that there's a slight color fading and some shrinkage.
Yeah,
the target pair of shrunk,
much more.
Whoa.
Color.
The best came up though.
The difference is obvious.
After 10 washes,
their color's faded slightly,
but they have clearly shrunk.
Huh?
Hey,
let's track like three inches,
man.
What is that?
It's a lot.
Okay.
No,
I bought a lot of clothing from target.
Some of the best shirts I've ever had in my entire life had been from target
black standards.
Yeah.
Sometimes tee shirts you can win.
Oh,
sometimes the cheaper the better.
Yeah,
that's,
target's got great clothes.
They've got a few that marina line.
Yeah,
he's really good.
I don't understand anybody that buys anything for a kid.
Not at a target or old navy.
I'm saying like if you go in there and you're like,
kids don't know what you're putting on them or you could buy an entire wardrobe
for $100 that's what we do for Lj.
I go online,
old navy and I buy all his shit and then you know he grows out of it in two
months.
Yeah.
Why would you spend,
but some motherfuckers been,
I know cause once a lot we went to some strip mall boutiquey place and I bought
her an outfit.
Yeah.
For like $100.
We're like,
oh no.
And I was like,
oh this is great.
And then you realize he puts it on,
he fucking throws shit on it and then he's like,
and then it doesn't fit like in a week.
So I was like yeah,
the last time I remember doing that.
And also with newborns.
They get you there.
I remember we were at target and they're like newborn shoes.
You're like,
motherfucker,
you're not going to put shoes on the newborn.
Don't even buy that.
The only thing you should buy for a newborn is onesies.
Yeah.
And fuck a snap.
I mean a buttons don't you dare get buttons.
Zipper,
zipper on everything.
Yeah.
They shouldn't even make children's clothing.
Clothing with the buttons.
Crazy Jean.
Yup.
It should is big time this weekend.
It's your,
it's your weekend back basically.
Yeah.
April 13th through 15th I'm going to be a Brad.
That's this weekend.
April 13th through 15th come see me.
I'm working out my hour.
Well that's already worked out.
I'm running the hour I should say.
And then April 28th and 29th Sacramento at the punchline.
May 4th and Fifth Phoenix Fart.
Nick's stand up live.
May 19th and 20th June dork titties at Gotham.
Come on you club.
June one through three.
I'm in mom ver.
What would we come up for?
Denver,
Denver
dog over at the dog.
Very common.
He works downtown location.
And then June 16th and 17th,
man friend disco at the punchline.
Come see me before I,
uh,
record this hour.
Very excited.
This is your boy t nuts and I have some major news dates.
Uh,
and in addition to the dates that,
uh,
you may have heard about this weekend,
San Jose meet rattle Washington.
There's a couple tickets left for the late show in Seattle at the more,
the first show is sold out.
Portland,
Oregon.
Both shows are sold out Saturday.
So I added shows in May,
May 13th.
I added a fourth show.
In other words,
a second show on May 13th,
which would be my fourth in Portland overall,
also at revolution hall.
Ryan sickler is coming with me,
the great sickle cell,
uh,
Eugene,
Oregon,
the night before,
and we added a late show in Portland.
If you didn't get tickets,
this is the last time you're going to get a chance.
Uh,
we have a month until the show and it's 10 30.
On May 13th,
they,
Saturday I added Tucson,
Arizona in Arizona.
The reality of theater.
June 9th.
I'm coming to Richmond,
Virginia,
Virginia Beach,
Virginia.
Um,
Greensboro,
North Carolina,
and Charleston,
South Carolina at the Charleston Guy Gay Yard Center.
Gayley I don't know how to say it.
Probably gaylords.
Um,
that's July 15.
Those are all in July.
Uh,
all at Tom,
cigarette.com/tour.
In addition,
I have added a reno,
Nevada,
Temecula,
the,
uh,
the Pachanga resort and casino.
Those are June 10 and 11.
And like I mentioned earlier,
the core denim,
the cone Denim Entertainment Center in,
uh,
in Greensburg.
What's it called?
Cone Denim Entertainment.
Seriously.
Seriously,
I swear to you.
That's in Greensboro.
North Carolina.
Wow.
You picked that specifically for the name,
right,
right.
100% picked that specifically for the name.
And uh,
I'm very excited.
I've never been,
I will be going there for the first time I've been in nearby,
but I've never been to a Greensboro.
Actually,
that's not far from where I went to college.
I've been to Greensboro.
You did.
We went to a wedding there.
You would,
you and me like,
seriously.
Seriously.
We went to a,
it was a case.
He's wedding may have been.
That was in Greensboro again,
not la.
I just call it la.
Not home.
You know what it is too.
I don't like to travel anymore.
[inaudible] I've seen a lot and I'm done seeing stuff.
I just want to stay here.
Yeah,
that's the truth.
I'm serious.
You know,
I don't really enjoy traveling anymore.
Yeah.
Traveling wears on.
You don't give a fuck.
Don't want to see it.
I'm kind of like your dad now.
Well,
you are smart in that.
Like for this upcoming,
you're going to all good places.
This is,
I want to go.
Yeah,
but I'm saying like for leisure.
For Fun.
Yeah.
No,
I want to fucking travel anymore.
Seen it all.
I've been,
I've been everywhere,
dude.
I've been all these fucking continents over it.
Just want to stay home.
Do you want to cringe at something?
Just that it's only,
it's only at someone's a naivete.
It's not like a a cringe like gross things prime.
Is it me from road rules?
No,
but this one is going to,
okay.
I,
it's one of those things.
You want something so embarrassing.
You have to turn it off.
Yeah.
It's called road rules a season six.
I listen to this.
This is a hockey player getting interviewed
policy.
Nelson Mandela,
one of the most significant historical figures in the 20th century.
What knowledge or awareness did you have growing up or when did you learn
nothing?
Well,
obviously growing up you,
yeah,
it's one of the most known athletes in the world.
Mandela.
Yeah.
What did you let us know now?
What do you know about Nelson Mandela?
Just so,
I just wanted to ask you,
I mean obviously Nelson Mandela,
one of the most significant historical figures of the 20th century.
What knowledge is so bad?
There's
not much,
well,
obviously growing up here.
Yeah.
This is one of the most known athletes in the world.
Okay.
Lot impact.
Any kind of sport that,
you know,
even playing hockey one knows him right from being the type of person that he
was off the ice.
Fortunate that he passed away a year ago.
But
is there somebody whose name sounds like Nelson Mandela?
Sure.
That's what will be the explanation.
Just,
you know,
he,
he changed a lot while he was with us and he's a hard guy,
huh?
Hockey and Johannesburg and you know,
maybe they're there.
Are they in Africa?
Cause it says giants of Africa behind them.
That's what I'm saying.
Oh,
I think you're right.
And it says Nelson Mandela Foundation.
So he's at Brady's in Joburg or something right there or at least something
affiliated South Africa.
Wow.
Uh,
I just think the way you met that is,
you know,
to me growing up playing sports and my parents was something really special
share.
Uh,
you know,
being,
try to be a leader too.
It says celebrating Nelson Mandela on that,
things like that where,
you know,
when your group sports do that one and that's it.
It's hard to watch.
It's hard.
I mean,
we're son of a bitch.
This guy thinks he was a hockey player and he,
and he goes on.
Oh my God.
Oh,
Toronto Maple leafs goaltender Jonathan Burn.
Yay on Nelson Mandela had a one year anniversary of his death fundraiser.
It is at his event.
And they're like,
fuck you guys a fucking,
yeah.
You think you'd look it up,
right?
Or you think you'd ask,
Hey,
who's Nelson Mandela and manners and he's a young guy.
He didn't grow up with apartheid,
apartheid,
but you know,
maybe black.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Maybe.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I mean fuck,
I know who he is,
but that's because I grew up in the 80s.
I heard of Nelson Mandela every,
every day on the news,
right?
Yeah.
That was a big story as a kid.
So here's a,
here's a,
I looked at,
I looked it up.
Um,
I guess this is old.
Yeah.
Because he,
you know,
it's a one year anniversary.
So this is,
we all miss,
make mistakes.
But a mistake could be magnified when you're a celebrity and you say something
incorrect.
Maple leafs goaltender learned this weekend when he said South African President
Nelson Mandela is one of his favorite athletes.
Maybe he could play hockey Nelson,
who knows.
Yeah.
Not a lot of a hockey rinks.
He apologize.
After a game.
I was embarrassed.
I didn't mean to offend.
Offend him.
His legacy.
I got flustered with the red carpet and I was nervous.
Um,
everyone makes mistakes.
And that was me that night.
Oh,
it seems like,
you know,
now was he,
was he in South Africa for the event?
No,
I don't think so.
no,
no.
That would have been even way worser.
They hosted it in,
I want to say maybe in,
in Toronto.
Canadia yeah.
That's hilarious.
Oh,
he just thinks everybody is a hockey player.
That,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well who knows?
Maybe he played hockey.
Yeah.
Tell me.
No,
I don't think he did.
Huh,
man.
And,
and,
uh,
I liked that those journalists did not bail him.
Oh,
this is gold decks.
Yeah.
Just let him,
if I can make a jerk out of themselves,
of course,
poor guy,
son of you,
take it,
ask if you're going to the fucking fundraiser,
right.
Like,
Hey,
who's,
uh,
who's this Mandela guy?
Right.
And it's ever heard of them.
And then to go and that,
which is okay,
he's a young guy.
Maybe he'd never heard of the man who,
you know,
yeah.
End to apartheid.
Spent time in prison.
Oh,
no.
Yeah.
I mean electric motor and 62 sprockets on the drive shaft as well as the input
and output yolks when there is no operating angle on the,
you joined the outpoured Yolk of the driven member that you joined the drive.
Shit,
blow my nose now.
Hold together as the same speed.
This is when you don't understand.
Watch the tape on these sprockets and listened to the sound.
The card makes as the drive shaft rotates at the same speed and you joined.
I want to so dumb.
Jesus.
That's terrible.
Yeah,
that was really bad.
You're black.
I remember when we went to South Africa and we had steaks every night around
midnight and gain so much weight that we had to buy fatter.
We're about the fattest clothes that they have in Africa.
We were the fattest people in Africa.
Yeah.
We gain weight.
An African fattest clothes.
We sell.
Seriously.
We went to the mall.
Yeah,
I remember.
And they're like,
oh,
we don't even have that.
Yeah.
Um,
we were so fat.
I think these people are African.
They're a covering a,
a Beyonce song.
It's pretty.
It's pretty great.
You want to hear it?
Yeah.
You play
it is Cape Town yet,
dude,
I left
everything.
Everything you want in a box in the close.
Hello my stuff.
Yes
miss.
That's fine.
Sorry.
We'll go back to like,
that was terrible.
That's really bad.
Horrendous.
Yeah,
I did that.
But at the doe come into the bay.
I think my,
my son and I could've done a better cover of this.
Woo Man.
Dude.
I left.
Was that an Afrikaans?
Well no that was,
that was English.
But it's clearly not their forte.
Yeah.
Hit that tee man.
Sounds like her.
Yeah.
We all day.
We all say
hello.
I miss out as Africa,
but let's go back.
I like it there.
That was actually a great trip.
We didn't go to Cape Town,
which a lot of people,
it was a bummer we didn't go to Cape.
Yeah.
Cause everybody was like,
how can you come here and not go to Cape Town?
But we just,
we were there two full weeks to four weeks and we went to Durban.
Joburg.
Yeah.
What else?
Um,
Urban Joburg.
One other places.
There's one more place I think.
Yeah,
well we went out to sweater sweater,
but we know we did shows in three places,
didn't we?
Yes.
I forget the third spot.
Nando's chicken.
Um,
sponsored it.
So we ate.
Now knows.
And what was the lady who was with Java?
Petty.
Petty Sauce,
right?
Trevor [inaudible] Plaza.
Bailey's Chavez.
Pleasure tomorrow.
Strava coms.
Pleasure.
Oh,
thanks for the,
uh,
the chicken.
Pleasure.
And I remember the very funny Ian bag was always offending.
Yeah.
People.
Oh Man.
But he could do it.
He would stop.
He would talk so much shit to Africans and they would laugh,
dude.
Yeah,
that was,
that was a fun time.
But fuck,
did we go man?
Why can't I remember?
Yeah.
Durbin.
Johannesburg.
What's the other fucking big city
you'll blank.
Oh,
South Africa.
Yay.
But it gets creepy after a minute.
Yeah,
that's right.
Pretoria.
No.
Yeah.
Joburg.
Pretoria.
So widow.
So widow,
we went to Nelson Mandela's house.
Remember,
we want to live.
What's up?
What's up dog?
What's up Nelson?
Okay.
You know what I'm saying?
Um,
it was fun.
It was such a great trip.
A lot of feedback online.
Uh,
on Facebook,
social media and a,
in the emails about a washcloth gate.
Oh No.
And we started a whole new debate.
Yeah.
This is,
people are,
are very upset.
I mean,
I'll tell you in person,
I was,
I was talking to people at shows and everybody was bringing it up.
You're kidding.
Yeah.
What's the consensus?
It was pretty split.
I mean,
it was,
it was nice of issue.
There was even a group that came up to me,
it was two couples and one guy doesn't listen to this show.
So they go,
Hey,
do you uh,
use a wash cloth?
And he was like,
what?
And they go,
when you share this,
it's like talking to me.
And he's like,
yeah.
And they were like,
Eh,
like you do?
He's like,
wait,
what's wrong with that?
And they're like,
it's just gross.
And then the other guy was like,
yeah,
what's wrong with your hands?
He's like,
well,
what's wrong?
Like it was just funny that he had no idea what's going on.
Here's an email.
Dear Tom and Christina,
I'm writing a end to let you know that your discussion about using a washcloth
from episode three nine he was truly horrifying to me as a non binary gender
fluid,
Hetero normative washcloth.
Okay.
It is deeply disturbing to me that you could suggest using a washcloth is only
for poor people using a washcloth.
I didn't say that.
Yes,
you are person
that's
using.
Oh Wow.
Is an effective way to keep the soap from slipping out of your hands being
washed away.
I can only assume that the poor butthole hygiene that Christina is constantly
whining about,
no whining about constantly stems from subpar washing habits such as these.
Right.
If you pick up a few washcloths and give it a shot,
you can finally get that butthole lake.
You have always dreamed of good luck shot.
No,
he's talking about me as I'm trying to tell you.
Oh,
you're saying that you complained about,
oh,
I'm whining about your butts.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Well we have a bit days Huller yeah,
the washlet three 50 he really takes care of them.
No washlet three-fifty V he is unbelievable.
Can you imagine she came off of that.
You want to get off my butt after I use that?
No,
no,
but my son accompanies me in the bathroom when we're alone in the morning.
Yeah.
I just haven't come in there and he watches me take a shit.
He likes to push the buttons to the bid day.
It's fun.
It's a family thing.
Yeah.
Dogs come in,
they watch me Shit.
Um,
yeah.
Another email.
Hi Christina.
Tom is not making up the story about an older woman masturbating at the laughing
skull bar.
I know that because I am that woman.
I am not crazy and I was not gone as you implied.
I am just an adventurous older woman who loves liking her being in public,
especially when a big hairy bear like your husband is around.
Sure.
I could tell he was enjoying the show.
Sincerely,
Mildred red bean.
Thank you.
[inaudible] I'm so sorry.
I offended you Mildred.
So there you go.
Right up.
Um,
who knew
why I didn't think you made up the story that somebody was masturbating.
Did I say that?
That I made that you were like,
that's not true.
Yeah.
Well,
it definitely happened.
Women don't do it as much as guys in public.
Dude,
here is something that somebody wants advice on.
Yeah.
Okay,
so let's,
let's see what you have for them.
Hey Jean,
I was listening to the podcast today while going through my standard grooming
routine while unloading my morning Brown,
I happened to notice something that I have a tendency to forget instead routine
my toenails.
My wife is constantly reminding me to clip them.
Yeah,
but I wear socks the majority of the time at home.
It doesn't appreciate when I tell her I am the toenail champ.
I know it should be standard practice to clip them off and,
but my man talents do get pretty gnarly.
Oh.
I want to know is what is a good amount of time between minimalizing my foot
raisers and what should I do to help me remember?
Thanks in advance,
Nasty Jake.
Nasty as shit,
right?
Change costume.
They are.
You remember you look at your nasty toenails,
motherfucker.
Tell me all these nasty is healing that is so nasty that you need a reminder
to just see how nasty you are then.
Yeah.
I mean I think
general rule is once you start seeing any significant length.
Yeah,
right.
And you just got the shit like toenail should be trim.
Yeah.
You know,
not super short,
but like,
you know,
it shouldn't be longer than the actual skin.
The Paj,
if you feel like as long then as long as long.
But he's like,
I don't remember that I have him loan.
That's nasty.
How do you forget?
Well and also it starts to,
it starts to encroach on your shoe wearing,
it'll start poking into your shoe.
No.
Have you ever done that where you're like,
damn I toenails are long and got trimmed them cause they're poking into my shoe
tab and to me before even feel it,
it's a little off that just,
you just see a man,
you just see it.
You're like,
this needs to get a trim.
Right.
You eyeball it.
When do you trim your toenails?
I Dunno,
I guess I can't think of how often they get done.
I feel like it's every couple of weeks.
Right.
Does that sound right?
How do you do it?
Do you get naked and then you put one foot up on the,
on the a sync?
No,
I just do it.
I just clicked the one to the floor in the bedroom anywhere.
Whatever room I'm in.
Okay.
But I mean,
I do that at home sometimes I do it in the hotel room,
but how do you do it?
You sit down with the toilet.
No,
I sit down.
I'll sit down either on that chair.
You have your vanity chair?
No.
You're not allowed to say yeah.
No leg up like this.
No.
Stinky.
Their clip.
Oh,
I'll do it on the edge of the bed.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Those are two places you're not supposed to do.
I do.
I don't give a shit.
No Shit.
Shit.
What'd he do with the clippings?
If you're doing it on the bed?
I just leave them wherever they go.
That's wrong.
Yeah,
but then I'm going to walk on it.
Our kids going to walk on it.
Yeah.
I figured the dog's lead it.
Sometimes it's fun to really examine,
um,
your big toe.
Okay.
Toenail clipping.
Of course,
when it's like real thick,
that's what everybody does.
Like,
whoa man.
It's all fascinating.
Yeah.
It's all yours.
Yeah,
but the little nails,
you're like,
eh,
but that big one,
if you get like a big chunky piece,
it's like the almond in the middle of those Chinese cookies.
Sometimes you get,
yeah.
I think you're doing it wrong.
Do you join them?
No.
Do you use them to floss?
Do you use them
as a tooth?
We do,
yeah.
Yeah.
Pick my teeth with them.
Do you think you could switch rooms and do it in the bathroom instead?
A,
yeah.
If it's convenient at the moment I'll do it.
Yeah.
No,
no.
That's the wrong answer.
Do you think you can just switch to the sanitary room?
Nah.
Yeah.
Okay.
You Nasty.
Nasty as hell right now.
So nasty like that.
Um,
stop the fucking toenails,
dude.
Yeah.
This guy,
I mean,
I don't know what kind of advice I could do that had the advice is just kind of,
don't be nasty.
He's like,
I have socks all.
Yeah,
but you don't have socks on all the time.
No,
no,
no.
When you just get in the shower,
that's what the best time to do it actually.
I'd say free shower.
Yeah.
Right.
Cause you,
you get down,
you're,
you're naked.
You look down.
Oh okay.
Clip him.
You're done.
That's what I do.
Or when I get out of the shower cause they're softer.
The only other thing he could do is set up a,
a,
a routine where like,
he goes,
it'd be great if a guy who doesn't normally cut his toenails starts getting
pedicures.
It's a great idea.
So you could just go get your treatment,
you know,
and it'll cut it for you.
That's true.
This whole people have to do,
don't old people go to the doctor?
I know a guy,
a podiatrist who told me that for a celebrity,
an old celebrity,
he would go to his house to kind of stuff.
No.
Do House calls for like a really famous guy who does it.
Is he dead?
Yeah,
he's dead.
Yeah.
But I don't,
it's like one of those Liberace.
No,
but it's somebody from like that era,
you know,
old school,
like a Cary grant type guy.
Ah,
I that'd be talking about like when he was,
you know,
85 or something.
That means somebody is going to have to do that for us.
Yeah.
And he said he would bring out the uh,
like the machine.
You can't just clip,
you'd have to like graze him down.
Nasty.
Why don't you just put like a memo in your calendar and your iPhone cut
toenails,
cut toenails.
Like put a reminder in there every two weeks.
Do you need that are paying attention?
Yeah.
It just looked down nasty.
Here's another email.
Hey Hitler,
it's me,
Danny.
Uh,
I've been dating my girlfriend for about a year and a half now.
She's got a beautiful daughter from a previous relationship.
As the relationship has grown more and more serious,
I'm getting closer and closer to the daughter.
Last few months I've pretty much taken the father role over completely and now
I'm starting to get complaints from my family about the smell of my breath.
I've always taken good care of my chompers.
You feel me?
Brush twice a day,
twice a day,
you know,
philosophy most days,
and you know,
regular visits to the dentist,
you feel me.
So I wanted to confirm that stepdad mouth is also a thing.
Keep them behind type stay glass.
And yes,
I date my mom p s mommy.
Tommy is the posture champ,
the personality champ,
the weight loss champ champ.
And most importantly the water champ.
Wrong,
wrong,
wrong.
I liked it.
I liked him up until that last sentence.
Thank you.
No Dad mouth is true.
Stepdad mouth and a lot of these can give you bad breath.
Your Diet can give you bad breath too.
Yup.
What you're eating,
what you're not eating.
Stan Umma flossing got floss.
Your teeth has the standing with the last day,
the,
somebody a saw this on local news and um,
wanted us to see a guy doing an interview of dropping your nose.
Sure.
I'm sure it's just crashing problems,
you know,
control arms,
stuff like that,
you know,
timelines,
so you,
it's a suspension on a car while show,
you know,
is,
is not good.
Wow.
Bloody nose.
Yeah.
Do you know,
cause you know,
you know,
so you know it's,
yeah,
it's weird that the guy interviewing him is also in the shot.
Yeah.
Nodding.
It could be one of those expos A's on dirty mechanics or something.
Oh right.
Like,
and he's like,
whatever buddy might be like,
whatever.
Right.
Because that guy seemed like a real fucking dirt bag.
Yes.
That's why he's nervous.
He's saying,
you know,
cause he's nervous.
It's a tick.
All right.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Hi foofy can I collect your urine fee left as you lift your leg so I can collect
your urine?
Um,
what do we have here?
One more.
Here we are.
Live today.
Dad bought her common Taylor.
I've Lucky Abbott.
Look at this.
Come on.
Lucky.
Get Rob.
They Assad.
Oh yeah.
Got To love.
Oh,
different angle from the reverse angle.
This is Richie Raleigh's angle from the rear.
Oh,
look at this.
Get up there.
That's what Catholic lay up.
Oh my God.
The rocket replay is off its head tonight.
What the fuck boring shit is this.
I don't know.
That is some fucking lame shit.
Should be the boring video in dirt.
Some people love that though.
Right?
You listen to Alex,
Matt,
there were some cars and dirt.
No kidding.
That's right.
That's all I have to say.
That's a lame place.
It's not la,
not la.
All right,
Jean.
Thank you to everybody for listening.
We can hear your beard scratch.
That's so gross.
They like it.
They get to hear all the oil and they like your skin flakes.
Did we play slap wagons and Mushy purples last week?
I don't remember.
You know,
have
no memory.
I know that's an old timers.
I Dunno.
Um,
thank you guys for listening.
Please get the shirt that's on sale now.
Uh,
there's also,
there's a bunch of,
uh,
merge.
I should also point out,
I'm very excited to announce April 28th.
Huh?
You're poly and by I'm Pauline by,
I also,
uh,
if you ever saw my special,
the second one,
mostly stories.
It comes out,
the audio comes out,
um,
on iTunes,
Amazon,
everywhere.
We're going to get a limited amount of hard copies.
I'm going to sign a bunch of them.
There'll be in our store and also in June it's going to come out on vinyl for
vinyl collectors and um,
I'll sign some of those too.
So please check out the album.
It's going to be in a few weeks.
Thank you for listening to your mom's house.
Podcasts by gene.
Hi Mommy.
[inaudible] is under control.
Those are mushy.
Yeah.
Slap wagons.
What?
Why is she verbal?
Slap wagons under control.
Those are mushy.
Billables.
Yeah.
Slap wagons.
Why?
Why is she verbal?
Yeah.
No slap wagons under control.
Those are my she with us?
Yeah.
Slap wagons.
Martin Martin.
Why is she verbal?
Yeah.
They'll snap wagons under control.
Those are mushy gutter balls.
Yeah.
What?
What,
why is she verbal?
Slap wagons.
Why is she verbal?
Yeah.
Slap wagons.
Martin Martin.
Why is she verbal?
Hmm?
Martin Martin.
Why is she verbal
slab under control?
Yeah.
Slab wagons.
Why is she verbal?
Yes.
Coaches coach this coach this it's
slap.
Slap.
Slap Martin Martin,
why is she verbal?